[Music]
that truck is ship needed antonescu
vehicle
[Music]
at its core Ghost Recon wildlands is
about information gathering the drug
dealers and terrorists you kill are just
obstacles between your special ops unit
and whatever clues you uncover hacking
an enemy's computer or interrogating a
wanted lieutenant can reveal half a
dozen more leads and you're given the
freedom to decide which lead to pursue
next wildlands is openness and the
flexibility of choice has so far been
one of its strengths moreover the first
10 hours of my playthrough amply
provided a diverse sampling of what the
greater game promises it took little
time to knock off the first batch of
objectives sample the local vehicles and
get reacquainted with Ghost Recon style
of tactical gameplay wildlands marks
Ghost Recon first foray into an open
world where it's bolivian setting is a
playground of both destruction and
distraction you can infiltrate a
stronghold with the best of stealthy
intentions but you have to be prepared
to wreak havoc the moment you're spotted
and the path to every main quest
destination is littered with potential
detours whether it be an optional piece
of Intel or a medal that gives you a
bonus kill point Ghost Recon wildlands
are expansive enough that using a
helicopter is a practical method of
transportation
given that the rocky region you start at
isn't especially off-road friendly the
best part of taking a helicopter is
jumping out of it and surprising enemies
from above provided you've unlocked the
parachute skills think of wildlands as a
less cartoony take on the Just Cause
series with the all business seriousness
one expects from a Tom Clancy game given
the pre-launch videos and trailers
emphasis on wanton mayhem and
nondescript missions with friends it was
pleasing to watch a couple scenes
setting cinematic shortly after firing
up wild lands even with the open-world
setting I'm hopeful it retains Ghost
Recon emphasis on narrative and goal
driven missions the ultimate goal is to
take out El sueño the leader of the
Santa Blanca drug cartel that
essentially runs Bolivia your CIA
contact Karen Bowman also has a
vindictive score to settle as one of her
friends in the DEA was kidnapped and
tortured to death by Santa Blanca while
revenge is a valid enough reason to
upend a narco-state in the clan severs I
suspect that Karen might have other
motives forming squads has been one of
wild lads more intriguing features
during these initial hours in keeping
ghost recons history of team foursomes
having a full squad made up of your
friends is
the ideal experience so far a team of
four humans with at least a modicum of
experience in tactical shooters is a
powerhouse in wild lands even though
enemy head counts adjust to scale with
the size of your team players who
already have a squad in mind might want
to consider starting off the game at the
highest difficulty however playing solo
with a squad of three AI companions
offers its own unique benefits when
coordinating a synchronized skill of
three targets the AI is reasonably
efficient in moving to reach
line-of-sight within seconds and they're
more durable than your friends when
taking fire which is immensely helpful
if they're out into open healing you
what is puzzling is that you can have a
mixed team of humans in AI if you and a
friend are playing a private session you
can't round off your team with two AI
operators what's more amusing is that
you still can hear the story related
banter between all four squad mates
I hate smart drops they make a sloppy
drunk dead there's comfort and falling
into a tactical routine with your
buddies as you reach the perimeter of
every enemy outpost this infiltration
cycle begins when you use your tiny
drone to survey the stronghold and mark
your visible enemies the ability to
track marked enemies through multiple
walls feels like cheating though that
hasn't diminished the appeal of the many
other tom clancy games that use this
feature the openness of wildlands makes
this tactic all the more essential and
helps your team decide on the best
strategy it remains to be seen whether
wildlands retains the same gadget of pl
Ghost Recon Future Soldier later on in
the game though perhaps the drone is all
the advanced tech need in Bolivia in to
ten hours have spent on the road to
liberate Bolivia from El sueño rule of
unlocked 20% of the map as I've slowly
made my way through the hit list of
underlings I've been curious about the
risks of sticking to the critical path
and whether there's such a thing as
being under levelled in wild lands that
said it's been easy to take brief detour
Stern extra experience and kills thanks
to the added efficiency of my teammates
AI controlled or otherwise whatever path
my journey takes I know it will involve
more diversions to earn extra abilities
to take downs of the bosses lieutenants
and the elimination of El sueño himself
which is tomato take an additional 30 to
40 hours stay tuned for our review in
the coming days
Roman this is nomads mantra spoke is
dead
[Music]